there's been all this talk about this
fire festival they just had this fire
festival the other day and everyone's
supposed to go to an island and all
these people paid a lot of money to hang
out with like you know rich people and
have this incredible experience and then
it was a disaster I looked at it and I
was thinking like well I never would
have gotten something like that do you
think you could have been suckered into
going to that I definitely would have
been there no problem if they were just
like hey one of the one the Kardashians
is gonna be there and also ja Rule is
gonna be there of course I will be there
just because now is like I mean I've had
way worse gigs I've been to Sacramento
several times that's where the next one
is Sacramento yeah what's up a
Sacramento punch line you suck yeah now
do you feel bad for the people that did
spend money and go to this let me guess
booty guess the answer feel too bad
about I do not if you had thousands of
dollars the goat on a trip to see blink
182 that's on you that is darwinism that
is fine
[Applause]
you